okay two and a half to play they put
yourself in a position to not only catch
him but to go ahead and win but they've
got to be pretty clean the rest of the
way
yeah and did witty for most part they
have held him again nothing here on the
quarter 16 at half 80 will bring it
across
take this down three two and a half to
play bounce it to Avery gets tilt down
with the sack of the basket turning
Anthony Davis LeBron got tapped on two
three in the mid to glue Nevada
18-footer Lakers last led third quarter
7371 they gotta keep get stops
[Applause]
[Music]
anyway
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
to shoot it and does to beat the clock
before the clock was all the way down in
what he put an Evert in a real bad
position faceting the ball with the shot
clock that low that's the aggressive
abroad we've been seen late games so
with the basket the Lakers are down by
ward that's a foul on Casey who's gonna
send the vert to the line to shoot two
he's one out of two from that position
and all the years - he's a 72%
free-throw shooter
good job by LeBron of attacking one
right by laverda
uncontested layup but now the Lakers in
a position where two free throws here
with a minute and 36 to play
get them down by that three of you is
right over there 50th of the yields
maintain their lead in the West
[Applause]
after a great weekend
call it there the midst of it right now
they're down by three again 102 99 they
don't need a freed agency to scratch
here to keep putting the pressure back
on the nest to score to judge what
LeBlanc did last time
basket of wanna finish
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you can't file you got a please get
defense now you're approaching the
one-minute mark there's not gonna
probably shoot till they get to about a
minute
did witty with 21
five what will adapt to double Piggy's
moves right way immediate benefit did
when he stands over Danny free travel
that's the guy to file yeah he's been a
lot better the last couple of years yeah
but still looking to arrives to eat oh
yeah no without question when he got the
offensive rebound and couldn't give you
another 14 seconds look hack-a-jordan
used to be completely the thing to do
but he's been shooting 70 percent over
the last two years after making only 45
percent the first
the defensive glass has hurt the Lakers
shortener revert back to the old form
not to start another steel in a position
where it could be a two-possession game
if the Nets take away the three-pointer
it's a three point lead right now
let up here
[Applause]
mr. legit was it white but Ana Lakers
convert off their that good play down
three that's it a minute LeBron Davis
we're tired
d43 timeout here it is that emphasizes
where it was a good foul two down three
you foul up off representing shooter he
listened to the lady answered the bail
with a triple - not to score steal 42
seconds to play so now you again got a
call upon your defense can you get it
when you need it
they got to score when they needed it
but now they need to stop when they need
it
so if you try to help got the best side
you're in trouble
that's way Spencer Dinwiddie top high
school Los Angeles California
look what they do their guard having a
situation in that doesn't look good
offensively LeBron back to get up
guarded by Chandler they've got to pick
by Bradley the broad was third team to
shoot South off his boy ahead of the
game
one looks to attack here he goes all the
way who's basketball
it's loose out-of-bounds Laker ball how
do they grow understand 4.83 mating Wow
LeBron gets right to the rim and somehow
again the ball touches every part of it
but doesn't go down as there close it up
with the left and it comes up short now
they're reviewing the suit who touched
this ball last the Lakers are holding
their finger holding or crossing their
fingers again this call is an overturned
right now on the floor to call the
floors Laker ball but we'll have to wait
and see what the officials rule Wow
and see they're battling for balance
worth of dignity touch it laughs or does
Danny Green touch it last
it might hit him on the leg or foot Roy
didn't touch him Bradley kcp a deal
abroad available kid witty and Prada
Green 5.1 remaining Lakers down 2
Danny Green gotta get it ain't finds
LeBron with four
the brought all the way ad the with the
game and Brooklyn has come in and
stunned the Lakers 104 to 102 Wow they
got a very good look at it I didn't
think they'd be able to drive and kick
that easily with only five seconds on
the clock but LeBron gets into the paint
draws DeAndre Jordan and wide open look
for Anthony Davis he just couldn't get
it to drop
[Applause]
for the Lakers there now shoo away a
make look and that is exactly what they
got amiss
[Applause]